قصفون صاروخيه استهدف حي ليننكي جنوبي
مدينه دمياط قالت السلطات الموليه لروسيا
انه تم باستخدام صواريخ هيمارس امريكيه
الصنع اطلقت القوات الاوكرانيه منها سته
صواريخ على هذا الحي طبعا هذا حجم الدمار
الذي خلفه صاروخان من اصل سته سقطت على
هذه المنازل السكنيه
وقالت ايضا السلطات بان القوات الاوكرانيه
اطلقت تلك الصواريخ من حي او من مدينه كره
خضراء التي تبعد بنحو 40 كلم عن هذه همم
المنطقه
لهم قطاعا للتيار الكهربائي هربت الى
الغرفه للاختباء وقامت جاران اخران وتطاير
الزجاج والغبار وكل شيء من حوله لنغادر
سنصلح بيتنا واصل للعيش فيه طبعا حجم
الدمار الذي خلفه هذا القصف الصاروخي على
حي لينيسكي جنوبي مدينه دونيست كان كبيرا
جدا
وتضررت نحو خمسه منازل سكنيه في محيط سقوط
هذه الصواريخ لكنه لم يكن القصف الوحيد
الذي تعرضت له مدينه دونيسك امس وايضا
صباح اليوم حيث اعلن مركز الدفاع المشتركه
عن استهداف حي سكي براجمات الصواريخ من
طراز وايضا
الى جرح اربعه مدنيين امين امين